now we've been discussing a bit on the
program so far as well parents and
children across the country are
wondering when schools are going to
reopen and how they can do so safely
many will be concerned about whether to
send their children back and also about
the impact that lockdown is having on
children's education particularly those
from disadvantaged backgrounds well to
talk about this I'm pleased to say we're
joined by the Chief Inspector of Ofsted
these schools regulator Amanda Spillman
thank you for being on the program this
morning now there are reports in the
newspapers this morning that primary
school children could return as early as
June is that something that you'd
support yeah I think I've been heard
Sophie saying that if you look at the
interests of children um it's very clear
that their interests are best served in
the vast majority of cases by being back
at school as soon as possible though of
course that has to be weighed up with a
great many issues for adults for the
staffing schools affect the health care
system but nevertheless if we look at
children it is in their interests
working out which children should go
back first how to do it in a safe way is
imperative of course and you can see
different countries doing slightly
different things France prioritizing
nurseries and primary schools Germany
slightly older children and according to
the reports today its primary schools in
the UK that could be been looked at do
you think it make sense to target
younger children there's a great deal of
logic in targeting younger children and
of course we know that norm at making
normality for children is really
important the younger the child the more
they need that that simples of
structured routine where they were they
understand what's what's happening it's
hard for them to to go to school one day
and then not for another two weeks
so I entirely recognize and sit and see
the logic of this and I also think
there's a logic from the point of view
of parents the youngest children are the
ones who need the greatest soar care and
oversight it's hardest for parent
parents to work and all the other things
they need to do if they're also looking
after and perhaps several it's several
young children at the same time and
trying to make sure they work through
school work remotely
I guess the difficulty is that the
younger children may also be those who
find a hardest to safely distance and
many teaching unions are quite worried
about the safety of their teachers
how difficult do you think it could be
to socially distance in a school setting
and what kind of measures might be used
to try and make sure that happens well
this of course is where we're in the
hands of the health experts to tell it
to tell it tell us what what what is
safe and how it can be organized and I
wouldn't want to second second guess
that for one moment but what we do know
and it's it's very clear there are
encouraging signs coming out that
children are both less somewhat less
susceptible and certainly to serious
complications and also seem to be less
likely to transmit so again I can't
second guess but I'm quite sure that
whatever decisions are being taken to
fully take account of the of the medical
and public health concerns yeah I mean
could you see for example school
children coming on alternate days or
alternate weeks just to try and ease out
the number of people in the classroom at
once I think a lot of ideas about
rotation to be of being discussed it's
as we can see from other countries there
doesn't seem to be someone obvious no no
brain or answer okay and now one of the
main challenges as well could be
actually convincing parents that it's
safe to send their children back to
school and the polling in the paper
today suggests many actually opposing
the idea of schools reopening still how
do you think the government is going to
convince people that they should
actually take advantage of the schools
when they do reopens
it's a really interesting balance we
have here because of course the harm to
children and to many children is largely
invisible some children are living in
really difficult circumstances where
they're not looked after well and those
aren't those those children aren't
visible to most parents at the moment
they're not out on the streets they're
not in school they're not in the
playgrounds and of course there's the
longer-term invisible harm of the
progressive loss of education which we
know is going to be contributing to
widening and widening gaps and the
longer children stay out of school the
harder it is going to be to pull that
together so it's all about finding
finding way to help people understand
the relative weight of the different
factors here I think and of course there
are many anxieties about which people
will need
surance and rightly so parents and
parents teachers other school skits
school staff they should they do need
that reassurance I think could you even
find parents who decide to keep their
children away from school as the current
situation now or before Crona virus well
given that there be substantial numbers
of children in households and where
somebody is at high risk
I think it's extraordinarily unlikely
that anybody would start at the stick
end of the spectrum rather than rather
than the carrot and I'm fairly sure that
we'll be running a mixed economy of
schooling for a work for a while yet
with with some children attending in
certain some children learning as best
they can remotely you were talking there
about the kind of invisible impact of
children not going to school and I'm
keen to talk about that a little bit
more as well because you know there are
real concerns about educational
inequality widening during the lockdown
you know not everyone's gonna have
parents who were homeschooling their
children every day will have the time to
or the ability to and how far back do
you think progress could be set that's a
really hard question to answer at this
stage you can do some sort of
mathematical calculations and say it
could be this but but the more important
point is that we've got the certainty
the children that you're their children
with special educational needs children
in households where it's difficult to
get even to get access to the equipment
or to the band with children who who are
living in in cramped households and of
course the children who just aren't very
motivated and most parents or many
parents know that experience of having a
child who for whom everything is laid on
but you just can't persuade them to take
it up and actually do it so so I think I
think we should be really clear that we
don't need to measure precisely which
children are being disadvantaged it's
just very clear that a lot are there's
also some very serious other impacts
that children can be going through to I
mean we know for example that cause two
domestic abuse helplines have gone up
children so often the victims in these
really upsetting cases as well and is
there something that you're concerned
about too absolutely it is and we also
know that look what that school
make most referrals to local authority
and other other services aver of various
kinds obviously because children aren't
most children aren't in school those
referrals aren't happening numbers are
down dramatically so so many children
are not being referred to or not getting
services that they absolutely need
there's a backlog building up and much
of that really needs addressing as fast
as possible and also children aren't
getting the exercise they're not getting
that there's a wider cultural benefit of
after after-school activities there are
many many things beyond not just getting
the the core academic subjects that are
accumulating here I was interested to
listen to your evidence to their select
committee earlier on in the week and I
just wondered if we could pick up a
little bit on something that you talked
about about whether or not Ofsted should
be judging schools on how they perform
during the lockdown because for many
people they'll be seeing some schools
doing very very well and setting lots of
virtual homework and catching up with
children and making sure parents have
got the support they need and other
schools falling behind and this could be
absolutely critical is it not Ofsted
this job to make sure that schools are
stepping up well we've been really
cleared routine inspection is suspended
at the moment and at the Secretary of
State's recoup request and when the vast
majority of schools have no more than a
handful of children attending that that
that I think is absolutely sounds
sensible and right and we don't have a
mandate to look at the remote work that
schools the setting and indeed there
the guidance that's been put out by
government makes very clear that schools
are not required to teach online the so
it'd be very odd for us to go out and
say you're not doing this well enough or
you're not doing enough of it I'm at the
point that schools are being told you
don't have to do it that would that that
would really create I think many
problems for the system um what's my
great problems for the system but at a
time when as we've discussed you know
there are real concerns about
disadvantaged children falling behind is
there not something that you should be
looking at well I think the vast
majority of schools are putting a great
deal of effort both into assembling
packages of remote learning whether it's
direct online lessons whether it's
access to some of the excellent
resources that have been put together
for online use like BBC bite-size oak
online
okay oak National Academies um there's a
great deal happening and but all of that
is still not going to add up to a full
education for children and it is not
going to prevent the gaps widening so
yes schools can and should can and
should be doing what they can but no it
would be wrong for us to protect it to
be to be going around track trying to
judge that in the absence of any sort of
clear expectation I would like to see us
get a clear expectation of what during
what it now seems clear is going to be a
longer period of lockdown we every
parent can and should expect of a school
but I don't think that's going going to
be simply have every teacher in front of
a camera every day okay I just finally
and I'm sure many of our viewers are
going to be grappling with homeschooling
their children trying to get their heads
around Pythagoras trying to motivate
their disinterested children to pay
attention to mum and dad and if you've
got any tips
it's a realtor is a real Tuffy very it
provides structure and routine remember
that's part of how schools do it as
schools do the magic that they do is to
is to is to give give children that that
structure that gives helps to motivate
children and get them through learning
which is of course hard yeah I think
perhaps lots of parents have a newfound
respect for teachers and thank you very
much for being the program today
thank you